hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to pack war there was no
intro screen to this game and you'll see
why it's called pack war very sighs
should start running right now oh god
okay
so huh that didn't sound good that was
probably right behind me why isn't my
mouth working properly that's not good
so this is a pac-man game if you
couldn't tell but there's two versions
of this game Oh God
okay so this is two versions of this
game that's that's not a good sound that
sounds like audio got broken almost is
that supposed to be happening okay I'm
just gonna assume that supposed to be
having this why I was looking for Oh
copyrighted or horribly copyrighted I'll
have to replace this but that's okay hey
hey I saw you over there hey come back
what is that oh well I guess the happy
fun times are over back to the nightmare
land so as you can tell this is a pacman
game Hey
Oh God how many of them are there so the
objective is obviously with most pac-man
games you do the thing that you do with
the pac-man and I'm gonna try to avoid
the power-ups because it didn't seem it
didn't seem to do though most that I've
ever seen in a game and hopefully Oh God
that's okay ah [ __ ] you
oh god but okay we're running running oh
I doubt we're running eyes on you again
well yeah oh they're all over me oh
they're all over
[ __ ] okay well that wasn't good oh good
golly Miss Molly just terrifying oh god
oh god no give me a bear up who care
give me a Bauer
oh god I ate the power up in this area
oh did I miss that bulb I did
Oh Frick Oh Frick all Frick dude Oh
Frick dude Oh Frick dude all Frick dude
everything's gonna be okay I suppose
maybe so one over here is oh okay
I got dual pistols this time that's
right back off
it doesn't do nothing it does absolutely
nothing
what good does that do it did nothing
yeah thank you
I know I suck I suck real bad oh wait he
died oh cool okay I'm just gonna try to
methodically collector I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead
yeah oh god I'm getting damaged imagery
- oh god this one has evacuate
keoki okey we're okay we're okay we
missed a few we missed a fee because
it's so easy to not pick him up even
though it should be easy to do pick him
up [ __ ] I just miss one right there
they're everywhere
ah right there oh god okay all right
we're okay fine
that's horrible to see the mouth just
closed over me like that knowing the
death is immediate and painful probably
like it's some attack on Titan [ __ ]
going on there I'm getting gobbled oh
why aren't they after the balls why am i
after the balls frankly I can do without
the balls frankly right oh god I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dying inside point of zero
that doesn't make any sense
all right let's try this again I'm gonna
try to actually be strategic about the
power-ups this time and be more
maneuverable because there are okay I'm
not gonna get that just yet there are
there are like whoa did I get the okay
there are I [ __ ] time for Bower up top
Ribeiro never Maura power up that it's
so cool the music is like so cool it's
ridiculously cool but if ha ha I gotta
get the power up give me the power gimme
gimme good good okay that's not what I
wanted ah that's right that's right
that's right that's right that's right
laughs oh God how many of them were
there there's only four ghosts in real
pac-man why has gotta be umpteen good
job thank you well that didn't work out
in my favorite pasta game over already
my guide twice there you guys have got
to play this game for yourself because
I'll try to replace the music with
something equally as cool but I don't
think I'm gonna find anything but
definitely play this game through the
link in the description below and you
can see for yourself like the amazing
thing you're missing out Oh doing much
better on this one than I have in the
past so got on my lives I don't think I
needed yet I do
think I need it I can do it I donated I
did it oh I need it I need it I mean it
I need it I need it
Oh get some
[Music]
blah blah this is my favorite party ha
ha ha
sorry you guys no idea what I'm talking
about so scientists I'm making random
[ __ ] baboon noises I mean that's kind
of what I do in all my videos oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
share my desk jack so we're on a good
path they're kind of congregated in one
area but I'm gonna that was a cherry
that was a cherry I don't know what the
cherry do but I want it I want that
cherry Oh doesn't know I'm here
they're totally ignorant to my situation
I gotta cut corners hey it's a key
coming over the door now I'm gonna keep
facet chitchat chitchat chitchat neck
Chetniks Chetniks rednecks [ __ ] NICs
Chetniks go around boy another powerup
there's a cherry
boink I got another life apparently
that's what that do you're ready for
some well Denise hell yeah oh yes oh yes
don't spawn there for you
Adi spun right on top of me what a load
of bag asses and they can steal two
lives if they just so happen to be close
ok I gotta get uh I gotta get to the
place so apparently I was just where
they spawned loaded ass here we go here
we go here we go yes yes yes yes yes yes
find a key I got a key
I got a key I got a gate I have the key
well the first day I use a key oh no
tell me I don't know I have I have the
goddamn key oh I have the key maybe I
need to eat all these you look good
oh come on
yeah damn it I had that okay I don't
know I don't know what I did wrong
besides not eat all the pellets cuz that
could be possible I had the key it said
I needed a key and it is there all right
you know what there's another version in
this game I'm gonna give that one to try
before I do this one I imagine as
equally as terrifying so BRB okay so
this one is the non-blood edition of
pac-man teleport key okay alright then I
think I'm good I mean it's kind of the
same scenario they're still they're
still gonna be after me it's just gonna
be less red less blood red and hopefully
less copyright once I get the power-ups
which I got to be very very very saving
on it but there's a bug in the game if
multiple people get you at once it means
you're dead twice I'm trying to clear
out the bottom as quickly as this is
just as terrifying this is just as
horrifying this is just as bad the only
difference is that it's not red oh god I
saw you
how's your tummy okay power up time time
to own some moans I'm compact [ __ ] oh
I got a lighter to justice copyrighted
yeah take me addicted really epic but I
need do not
channel exploded I'm gonna be boned
because now I have no idea where I
missed any and I don't know where the
key would be so I'm kind of just left to
wander the halls for a while till I find
what I need I don't know when that's
gonna happen there's got to be a space
up in the top portion of the map because
I do not who I do not think that I got
that 100% there's got to be something
like just one pellet one pellet baby
come on come on do it for me come on
Oh God not that that's not what I wanted
you're a big fella die don't want you
you gobble something else I mean I know
you want to do a lot for me pac-man but
you know frankly I'm a little tired I
got a headache I don't need any of that
the worst thing is if you make a wrong
turn you're you're immeasurably boned
you're so boned you fall into the bone
pit of despair where you're gonna be
boning for all eternity but not in the
good way because you're just going to be
bone every of the bone demons is gonna
bone you until the end of own time and
bone time ain't fun time yeah I've
checked everywhere that's okay all right
check TEVAR II where I couldn't find a
key so I don't know if that's his
brother
okay hi how are you doing he's stuck
stuck hello buddy
hi buddy how are you doing oh you want
some or you want some of my sexy body
well you can't have it you can't have it
you couldn't handle all of this sexy
now with that stupid mouth of yours oh
never mind then okay so that's the end
of that but thank you everybody so much
for watching I highly recommend this
game because I don't think I can
honestly show you guys the music that's
in it but if you check the game out
there's a link in the description you
can play for yourself it's really cool
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]
freaking everybody out okay it was
giving a little more to kill us now